that's going my dual snapples my name is
PIP and welcome to three free games of
peds our first game is cat herding
totally on one so this game is all about
herding cats so here we have cookie and
we have biscuit are they stupid or some
[ __ ] what are they doing what are you
doing it it what this [ __ ] calm down
cookie what are you doing making out
with each other
look there's memes inside the game
that's how you know a game is good
where's the MLG noscope seriously okay I
can choose a laser pointer as well Jesus
what happened what are you doing you're
crazy
screw BuzzFeed Thank You someone who
understands get the cookie Wow
attack cookie destroy the memes once it
for all cookie what are you doing what I
told you about defying gravity cookie
why did I tell you
all right what about the horn what kind
of horn is that it's making me there's
something adorable and very very
terrifying at the same time about this
game what what look what you did Katie's
I told you not to merge the door with
the walls and what do you do what kind
of drugs am i feeding these cats
there's pancakes mixing there must get
the pancake mix yes pancake mix oh no
I'm trapped forever
like stood ours level one the beach a
lovely place to drink a soda
this game has opened my eyes there's no
[ __ ] ground how do I drink how do I
their way out but ah that's good
I need more sodas you wish you could eat
the soda I wish that every day plain
they really know how to make graphics
these days huh the next-gen consoles can
really learn a thing if they pet it
tension to PC master-race
look at that son ah it's blinding me so
so bright ah you think the floor would
be brighter but I would sand that's what
it is my bad
how could I not see that I reek as you
could just shut the [ __ ] up about the
soda hey let's drink some more soda
shall we thank you I wonder what's in
this soda probably a mixture of AIDS and
crack I don't know how else do you get
an experience like this [ __ ] okay did I
not collect all the [ __ ] sodas or
white what's up if there's a way to get
I wonder if there's a way to get milling
so does the unanswered questions of life
well now where the [ __ ] is that last
soda it's kind of like I'm drinking it
through my nose too like I wish that I
could eat I wish you would turn up the
[ __ ] fan when you record audio
samples how about that where is the last
soda you kidding me that house looks so
nice oh it's a light house of course my
bad
alright you know what I'm done life is
too short to waste it on this [ __ ] last
game bros gotta make myself pretty for
you oh yeah it's on
even Edgar's like Go Go Power Rangers
press Start
well [ __ ] attack they jump and I say how
to do it you just [ __ ] do it
sorry senpai the nostalgia man oh my god
then the stout kind of characters this I
don't know why but my favorite was
always the Asian girl don't really [ __ ]
yeah huh-huh-huh-huh whoa dad backflip
or whatever watch Jesus
oh god that guy looks suspicious hello
oh my god who woulda thunk it smacked
him [ __ ] up I love how they jump in
like hello hi there you have a moment to
talk about Jesus let's go to the mall
you guys need to shuffle better outfits
cuz those are [ __ ] fabulous where did
you get it
Tiffany sorry Oh God ah Jeff no what -
[ __ ] what is that yeah Howard a guru
powered back I'm a little Asian woman
suck my ass are waiting here now oh
Jesus that's a what the hell is that guy
doing like I give zero [ __ ] huh oh [ __ ]
deaf who the hell are you
no no power oh [ __ ] power daddies
why are you [ __ ]
loaded we like I still give Sarah [ __ ]
this is so badass but my hair is not
good enough really like about that
alright now we're talking after their
victory the Rangers contacted Zorgon of
course alright let's try another
character I mean I had the Jason figure
I might as well go with it run a soros
so [ __ ] cold how what is that his
junk is dangling
what does [ __ ] decide but but what I'm
talk but hey we're back in the day you
had to make a noise on every move
Oh got it Wow some of them know how to
ride a motorbike oh let's that's
impressive I thought they were all in
special need I got him
yes oh who the [ __ ] are you oh god oh
god kill it kill it fast Jesus what is
that send a demon
are you a demon who wears that kind of
outfit only I can wear no food like that
and pull it off oh god what happened to
your ears you got a necklace out ah [ __ ]
you in your name Lewis I don't care how
fabulous you are damn I hate the bikes
Oh God I would have bought it what is
this me [ __ ] camel toe [ __ ] what what
was that that was that call please tell
me that was cool I will finish those
pesky Power Rangers off grow grow grow
hmm yes mr. ty twist Tiger Zord
oh god oh this is so cool they all like
went together and they did oh god it's
so [ __ ] cool
area 2.2 I'm the scigirl Ord Tiger Lord
why do I keep saying that I've got to
see you again huh did you grow or like
what happened Oh God
two of them at the Somme Tom what's up
my ass whoa peace out brothers Oh area
clear
do something badass there it is the
Rangers aren't able to contact Zordon
feeling that their base could be under
attack that guy is what is he doing like
[ __ ] is that I also really like a black
guy Master it's always on crack or some
[ __ ] I don't know what's going on this
game is awesome all right I don't have
more time to play but if you enjoy
watching Prez which i think you did hit
that like button and thank you for
watching and thank you for being a pro
thank you for being a ho let's be honest
here you're pretty [ __ ] I'm just
kidding stay awesome brothers love you
you